welcome back to cbs mornings we showed
you earlier how president biden is
pushing for all americans to be
vaccinated against covet he and other
vaccine advocates face a lot of
opposition in many parts of the country
political tensions are spilling over
into health care and there are cases of
hospital workers coming under attack
jonathan bigliotti visited a covid ward
in idaho where only about half of the
eligible population is fully vaccinated
he saw firsthand how doctors are
struggling
we have now had to
convert day surgery
to a fourth intensive care unit space
icu director dr megan mcinerney is
normally the last person you want to
meet at saint alfonse's hospital's
growing covid ward if you're sick enough
with kovid to meet me
your chances of dying are pretty high
about 50 percent of patients who have
been intubated in recent months have
died there are vaccines available to
prevent the very scene before our eyes
and yet here we are yes
right it did not have to be this way
hey alicia how's it going today
mcinerney's colleague dr carolyn
mcfarland says misinformation and
political division over vaccines have
become an unexpected and deadly side
effect of idaho's covet crisis the
divisiveness that we saw
with politics i'm seeing that same kind
of trend in health
and that alarms me that i'm treating
patients for their political views
whereas this virus does not care
in idaho it's not required and even
frowned upon to wear masks indoors many
don't i thought this would be bringing
america together to fight a common evil
as more sick residents fled hospitals
some medical staffers are leaving saint
alphonsus has lost 50 percent of its
entire staff since covet began mostly
due to burnout
we do often get
family members be raiding us up one side
and down the other charge nurse alicia
luciani has had enough today is her last
day in the ward what's going on your
mind right now
[Music]
there's just so many of them
i've put more people in body bags over
the last two years than i have in the
last nine
it's hard
and there's just a heaviness
[Music]
so
that
um in an effort to preserve my own
mental emotional health was a uh
helped with the decision to
do something
a little different
the exhausting and polarized climate has
also led to troubling protest signs like
this one outside the er calling doctors
murderers
i feel for all of us who are trying to
fight
fight against covet and provide care and
that's what the greeting is
now more than 18 months into a pandemic
that once celebrated these workers as
heroes dr megan mcinerney says today she
thinks twice about wearing her scrubs in
public
is it because i feel unsafe i don't
necessarily think so but i'm certainly
not going to put myself out there i'm
not going to you know put up the sign
that i'm a health care worker
once celebrated as heroes today some at
times feel like the enemy one rn in this
icu actually left to become a checkout
clerk at the local walmart she said the
stress the long hours and the
frustration simply became too much gail
boy jonathan it's a heartbreaking story
because all the medical people want to
do is save our lives and i'm wondering
how they're coping and what they tell
themselves to keep going when it seems
their work may not be appreciated
because of politics makes no sense to me
yeah it makes no sense to me too these
are incredibly strong people a few
minutes into each of our interviews all
of them at points started to cry the
hope that they do have comes from the
lives that they do save there are so
many people in the overflowing covet
wards here when one person gets out they
jump around here in this icu to
celebrate those small victories to get
through it all
yeah they should please know a lot of
people appreciate the work they do and
we need them desperately jonathan we
thank you